[Musique]
une entreprise dédiée à toute la partie
réglementation pour les dirigeants et le
personnel dans les métiers de bouche
donc nous parlons essentiellement aux
restaurateurs aux boulangers au blue
chez donc toutes les personnes qui
manipulent des denrées alimentaires
nous travaillons sur trois axes comment
répondre à la réglementation et
l'hygiène donc toute la partie haccp
comment répondre à la répression des
fraudes donc tout ce qui est information
aux consignes aux consommateurs et
comment répondre à la réglementation ou
droit du travail durant le confinement
nous on a souhaité garder le contact
avec avec nos clients et les autres n'a
organisé environ tous les quinze jours
oui nanard pour permettre aux
restaurateurs les mêmes aux futurs
restaurateurs de pouvoir participer et
avoir des informations sur comment
s'adapter riz comment mettre en place
certaines choses
c'est une formation qu'on a voulu simple
abordable et puis aussi pas très longue
donc qu'elle dure sept heures on a
beaucoup d'informations qui nous sont
parvenues donc de l'état et c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une
formation qui complètement collés au
protocole et qui leur permet de répondre
à ce protocole dont sur toutes les
lignes
comment je mets en place mon plan de
maîtrise sanitaire renforcée durant
qu'ovide comment je vais communiquer à
mai avec mais à mes salariés pour qu'ils
puissent être partie prenante de cette
nouvelle méthodologie de travail